et
on reste à marseille ce matin avec notre
invité politique c'est renaud muselier
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
renaud muselier vous êtes le président
de la région sud provence alpes côte
d'azur on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes renaud muselier vous étiez
membre des républicains vous avez quitté
ce parti vous avez apporté votre soutien
à emmanuel macron que vous soutenez
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'un retour au
gouvernement vous tenterez
n'ont montré clairement non j'ai été
deux fois ministre pendant trois ans
avec le président chirac j'ai vécu une
crise internationale majeure quand
j'étais au quai d'orsay avec l'irak et
j'ai entendu avec beaucoup d'attention
ce qu'ils veulent être des inventions
sur la crise la guerre des sorties de
guerre est donc aujourd'hui je préside
la région provence alpes côte d'azur
j'ai l'honneur d'être président pour
jusqu'en 2028 j'élargis ma majorité en
vins qu'on va partir en difficile
puisqu'on me donner si maintenant
perdant sur la base de ce que je suis
historiquement c'est à dire un gaulliste
rpr membre fondateur de l'ump mon
fondateur de l air membre du bureau
politique de la ceni donc
qui a été condamné par sa famille parce
que j'avais voulu additionnés ça m'a
permis de gagner contre le front
national contre thierry mariani qui
lui-même
permettait de dire à madame le pen
qu'elle était qu'elle avait changé et ça
aurait été peut-être à la crimée en
région provence alpes côte d'azur avec
avec la france cette majorité m'a permis
de
2-1 axe très fort environnementales
sanitaires de développement de la région
je peux le faire et le président macron
qui m'a aidé quelque part dans ma
réélection ce que n'a pas fait beaucoup
ma famille et mon ex famille politique
mais on voit aujourd'hui que ce choix
stratégique de de courir un grand écart
sans jamais définir sa ligne politique
s'il est sans jamais tranché entre
l'extrême droite où la macro ni en leur
disant je leur ai dit la seule fois
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous n'êtes
pas au deuxième tour ont toujours
répondu on va gagner ok enfin l'arrêté
c'est que finalement les électeurs ne se
sont pas retrouvés les élèves ont sombré
et j'en suis navré pour eux d'ailleurs
mais je les invite aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui au lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle qui a très clairement dit
au premier tour lr pc ps verts dehors
avec -2 5% qui ont radicalisé les camps
avec la droite et l'extrême droite qui
radical qui ont radicalisé la gauche qui
aujourd'hui est en train de se
recomposer dans un système radical
d'aller auprès du pouvoir de monsieur
macron en dix ans mes amis et et les
électeurs et verts l'ont bien compris
d'ailleurs puisque il ya un sondage qui
va dire que ce sont 15 % derrière
souhaité faire en sorte que monsieur
macron soit élu et voterez pour monsieur
macron on va pas rester nous les excès
leur salaire avec salaire c'est réglé
mais les excès l'air prendre près de
quinze ans sans être pouvoir nous une
famille politique de la droite et du
centre qui qui qui qui sont une famille
de gouvernement qui gouvernants au
niveau des mairies des départements des
régions mais je sais qu'en dehors mais
justement regardez-la déjà que de plus
mais justement vous le dites vous
gouvernez au niveau des vous avez
remporté les municipales vous avez
remporté les départementales vous
gouvernez une partie des régions est ce
que du coup ça ne justifie pas le choix
d'indépendance des républicains y a pas
que la présidentielle mais mais mais je
pense qu'elle avait plus qu'à se
trompent là on parle d'une élection
nationale
dans une élection nationale on vote pour
le national on est un pays quelque part
belle à partie sur les besoins des chefs
qui lève une armée une armée à un projet
politique et dans sept projets
politiques pilotée par le chef il ya un
combat pour la france notre pays qui est
un grand pays du monde bon là
aujourd'hui regardez depuis l'élection
présidentielle depuis le deuxième tour
on n'entend plus parler de rien un
tailleur de l'excellent r2 aller à part
dont l'idh rien voilà si ce n'est lors
désastre politique et il se
recroqueville comme peau de chagrin sur
leur propre territoire disons parce que
nous avons été élus au niveau local ou
gagneront niveau national 90 se trompent
pas les français sont pas stupides il ya
les élections locales les élections
nationales aujourd'hui elle est au
niveau national le ps rien normaction
moment là ne peut en rien leurs leaders
locaux n'accèderont jamais au pouvoir
national donc j'invite les élèves à
revoir sa position au candidat a l'air
de dire mais nous on veut travailler
pour gouverner avec une idéologie une
volonté de droite quelle autre formation
notre idéologie notre volonté mais nous
ne sommes pas contre le pouvoir central
sinon tu disparais son aîné
disparaîtront a rejoint a rejoint de
monsieur macro pour qu'on soit clair les
nerfs ils doivent résister à l'esa pour
eux sinon les élisent les leurs ils
doivent rester lr c'est à dire que le
parti doit se maintenir mais travailler
avec emmanuel macron selon vous ou
est-ce qu'il faut que les républicains
disparaissent fini le parti ils doivent
se dissoudre et elle est dans un parti
unique avec emmanuel macron c'est quoi
votre ligne clairement
vous savez moi je fais partie d'une
famille politique qui a évolué qu'à
changer de nom un grand nombre de fois
tu allons donc qu'on n'est pas forcément
fondamentalement
accroché au nom de r n'a été
rpr pour ma part moi je suis un pur
produit du rpr et je reste
idéologiquement et fondamentalement rpr
après on est passé à l'ump après il a
été créé les nerfs sont des outils
politiques qui nous ont permis de porter
une idéologie rassembleuse un projet
politique fédérateur autour d'une
personnalité comme jacques chirac ou
nicolas sarkozy qui est aujourd'hui
critiqué lui-même dans sa famille l air
c'est quand même une histoire de fous
étaient donc
évoluer et doivent évoluer et l'ailière
doivent évoluer à l'intérieur dame
acronis est évident un mot puisque on va
parler nicolas sarkozy mais vous parlez
de jacques chirac vous qui êtes
chiraquien vous êtes un chiraquien
historique renaud muselier jacques
chirac et en 2002 il avait refusé un
gouvernement d'union nationale parce
qu'il disait qu'il ne fallait pas
laisser le monopole de l'opposition aux
extrêmes est-ce que ce que fait l air
aujourd'hui cfa dans la droite ligne du
chiraquisme est-ce que se fondent dans
le maquereau nice n'est pas laisser
l'opposition à marine le pen
mais avant on avait une armée de
militants une famille politique des
leaders charismatiques jean luc hess
commun n'a plus de leader plus de
militants et vaguement un tissu d'élus
locaux c'est petit plus du tout le même
contexte de surcroît la vie politique
nationale a complètement évolué à
l'époque vous aviez la droite et le ps
le ps avec ses alliés aujourd'hui le ps
est obligé de baiser la babouche le
monsieur mélenchon sont soumis très bien
et nous l heure les repères à l'époque
avec sa puissance de feu ce qui n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui
est ce que vous allez
est ce que vous allez mener campagne
pour les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle est ce que vous allez
allez adhérer
la majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui
où vous restez libre
non je reste du monde alors ça c'est la
première des choses et gagner cette
liberté après 35 ans de militantisme
dans ma famille politique ce
militantisme c'est en sorte que je
n'adhérais pas une démarche aujourd'hui
de deux d'écurie présidentielle
donc je n'adhérais pas donc ça ses
horizons je n'adhérais pas à la
république en marche il y a dans la
macro ni en quelque sorte une forme de
galaxies dans lequel vous avez des gens
de droite des gens de gauche je dirais
que des gens modérés et raisonnables ce
qui est tout à fait mon tempérament même
si je suis un garçon parfaitement
déterminé la république un marché pas
pour moi tout le volet de gauche avec
des personnalités comme monsieur le
drian ou madame bornes sur les
personnalités que j'aime beaucoup
demeurant à qui j'ai beaucoup travaillé
en tant que président de région ou
présidents des régions de france mais
ces gens que j'aime travailler avec eux
j'aime échanger avec eux ne sommes pas
ma sensibilité travail je vois sur le
volet droite horizon c'est plutôt une
culture de d'écuries présidentielles je
n'irai pas et donc gérer à l'intérieur
de la macro ni dans un volet de droite
de la mode roth des territoires de
droite pour servir mon pays par internet
mais terry tour parce que j'imagine dans
une refonte d'un appareil politique qui
sera juste deux questions pourquoi
horizon c'est une écurie présidentielle
selon vous edouard philippe c'est pas le
mieux placé pour faire cette alliance
entre les élus de droite à la majorité
présidentielle que vous soutenez
si leurs philippe est parfaitement bien
placé et il a montré en fin de premier
ministre qu'il avait un sérum de
capacité et de talent que je reconnais
parfaitement et d'ailleurs j'ai
parfaitement travaillé avec lui pour
autant il veut être candidat à plaisance
de la république au chaud pour apaiser
les choses
si si bien sûr je l'aï largement la
capacité d'être président de la
république mais moi c'est pas mon
problème aujourd'hui moi je moi je
m'engage dans une démarche qui est à
dire il y à un quinquennat qui arrive
devant nous on voit bien que la la
classe politique s'est radicalisée
radicaliser parce que les gens souffrent
ne comprennent pas sorte de deux ans de
kovy 2d gilet jaune il faut apaiser
réformer et pour ça il faut s'appliquer
et ne pas rentrer pour ma part en tout
cas dans une suite logique qui est de
dire qu'ils y aura-t-il après le prêt
public présent la république à cinq ans
pour travailler se représentera pas
donnons les moyens soyons avec lui pour
restructurer réforme et aider la france
à se développer et je le ferai de ma
région où il ya une base ici une logique
stratégique stable calme apaisé qui est
indispensable pour le débat politique et
public compte tenu de l'environnement
général avec la guerre à nos frontières
oui mais on va voir de la manière dans
quelques anciens manière dont vous allez
faire le rassemblement national est
juste un mot sur nicolas sarkozy d'abord
nicolas sarkozy pour vous il doit
prendre la parole dans cette campagne
des législatives
je suis très ami avec nicolas sarkozy il
m'a beaucoup aidé dans la campagne
régionale pour essayer de trouver les
meilleures formules contre le front
national et fait en sorte que je puisse
gagner
c'est un homme politique est le plus
capé qui a le mieux réussi qui est un
grand sage et qui en même temps très
déterminé je laisse exprimer mais le
fait qu'il était reçu par le président
de la république cette semaine montre
bien à quel point qu'ils continuent à
peser dans le débat politique vous êtes
encore en contact avec lui aujourd'hui
vous les avez parlé récemment
bien sûr
ça c'est moi mais ça va on est dans un
schéma politique en france où chacun
fait valoir c'est un peu comme les
crêtes des coques vous savez je les ai
eus je les ai vus je lui parlais j'y
suis passé je suis venu la nuit vraiment
je rentre pas dans ce jeu là je suis
valoir mort aux forces politiques eux
c'est 1 500 fanfaronner ont claironné
les choses en permanence moyennant quoi
on sait plus qui est qui qui fait quoi
maintenant comme personne ne parle mais
ce qu'ils oeuvrent lui est ce qu'il vous
a dit si le vrai un rapprochement entre
les républicains et la majorité
présidentielle
est ce que vous pensez une seule seconde
que le poison de la république a reçu
l'ancien président république pour
qu'ils boivent un café ensemble tout
simplement que ça je ne crois pas il
travaille sur des législatives sur des
candidatures communes
août et c'est pas les mécanos tous les
deux de la vie politique française avec
des circonscriptions mais je pense que
sa politique qu'on valide lui-même les
candidatures majorité à avoir un pays
stable ils le font le rassemblement
national et fort la macro ni d'un
juste qu'on ne vous aider le
rassemblement national efforts dans
votre région est ce que pour vous ils
peuvent obtenir plus de députés en
région sud que les autres partis
ce nom je suis un peu précieux en tout
cas c'est que les élèves vont perdre
beaucoup alors donc un profit de qui je
sais pas nous les excès l'air il y en a
bien à 15 aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils
vont revenir entre 1 et 3 voilà
on a dans la région provence alpes côte
d'azur qui est toujours très forte pour
leur international mais qui fait en
sorte que globalement quand même quand
on nous annonce aux municipales qui vont
pendant 17 et 20 villes ils en prennent
d'eux c'est qu'ils avaient quand on nous
explique aux régionales qui vont gagner
la région haut la main je fais le
meilleur score de la droite en france
madame d'être bienfaisants le meilleur
score de la droite de la gauche en
france
donc ils sont très forts mais gagne pas
les élections locales au niveau des
circonscriptions il ya quarante deux
circonscriptions dans la région pour ans
après d'azur vous aurez 28 macron le pen
vous aurez 6 bat kron
mélenchon et après vous aurez 8
mélenchon le pen voilà comment ça est en
train de se définir le dispositif et
c'est à dire vous voyez à peu près
combien de députés pour chaque nous
avons le ferons quand même nom mais là
vous nous avez donné les duels de second
tour que vous voyez au final vous
imaginez combien de députés pour chaque
partie vous connaissez bien votre région
de ça je je je ne veux pas bien voir
encore parce que vous avez c'est
peut-être un peu encore tout c'est
encore un peu tôt vous avez des
territoires qui se perturbent avec les
candidats quand vous avez contre
monsieur ciotti
zemmour qui se présente face à l'aide
mécaniquement pour survivre au deuxième
tour est ce que le taux de participation
permettra des triangulaires uno comme
souvent nous sommes à bank dans le sud
je ne le crois pas donc sur les deux
premiers qui sortent en fonction des
endroits où il ya des alliances le plus
ou moins dosé lalonde on se retrouve ou
malsaine on se retrouvera avec des jeux
un peu différente mais c'est tout à fait
à la marge donc je vois pas une très
grande poussée du fro j'ouvre une grosse
chute de l air et je vois là
les élus de maquereau est très bien
placé il faut faire très attention vous
voyez une zone comme par exemple ect ect
c'est la première un peu c'est une des
premières villes de droite de macron en
france avec un très gros score ça c'est
une vraie ville de droite et larissa
conscription de monsieur mélenchon il ya
deux erreurs sur aix dans la
circonscription de monsieur mélenchon
mac ont fait un énorme score au deuxième
tour et pour autant il n'a aucune chance
de gagner hamon pour revenir sauf que
vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué
effectivement eric zemmour reconquête a
fait le choix de ne pas présenter de
candidat face à eric ciotti qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
moi je pense que c'est ça prouve bien la
dérive de mon ex parti on excommunie
systématiquement les personnes qui
veulent travailler avec monsieur
monsieur macron alors que ça fait partie
de notre culture notre adn à l'époque et
d'ailleurs c'est à droite et le centre
ont on additionnait les compétences et
là on les veut pas côté macro et quand
quelqu'un de l air mandat de la
commission nationale d'investitures ce
trop trouve de fait soutenue par par
zemmour en ce moment avouez que c'est
quand même une dérive à l'extrême droite
qui est tout à fait intéressante à
analyser mais qui prouve bien que nos
électeurs nous ex électeurs aient l'air
ne ne s'y retrouvent pas mais ces deux
fêtes vous l'avez dit eric ciotti n'a
pas demandé à ne pas avoir de candidat
d'eric zemmour face à lui qu'est ce
qu'il aurait pu faire qu'est ce qu'il
aurait dû faire selon vous
comment vous savez où qui l'a pas
demandé vous pensez qu'il a demandé avez
vous pensé vous pensez qu'il va demander
que c'est lui qui a demandé à ne pas
avoir de candidat face à lui
vous croyez que monsieur ciotti les
choses lui arrive par hasard comme ça
vous croyez que c'est bizarre on
n'entend plus du tout en ce moment
d'ailleurs plaisir quand pouvons souvent
ici on sent les choses y avait quand
souray et négocier avec l hexagone
allez
je sais pas je vous pose la question il
ya un double jeu d'eric ciotti pour vous
il ya toujours un trip point cadres ou
peu joué avec lui on va juste un mot sur
la gauche puisque la gauche vous le
disait elle a trouvé un accord pour les
législatives
accord entre toutes les formations de
gauche les socialistes ont signé hier
vous vous l'avez vécu ça à marseille 1
aux municipales où benoît gagnon était
le candidat commun de toute la gauche
c'est un danger pour pleurer emmanuel
macron cet accord de gauche
en tout cas c'est très bien fait de la
part de monsieur mélenchon et qui
kiffent acquis et qui finalement
écrabouille la totalité de la gauche en
radicalisant la gauche derrière derrière
son panache il a fait une magnifique
campagne et il a écrabouillé tourne donc
aujourd'hui ce qui est ce qui est
désolant pour la gauche je parle par
exemple pour le ps eux qui sont les
héritiers de charges jaurès de
mitterrand des hollande une
philosophie politique très importante
est très fort dans notre pays ils ont
tout abandonné pour quatre sièges et de
cacahuètes donc c'est quand même très
impressionnant ce besoin absolu de
survivre au profit de rien je constate
que les grands leaders de gauche que ce
soit madame delga où
l'ancien premier ministre ne s'y
retrouve pas elle n'accepte pas sa
démarche là je trouve que c'est eux qui
ont moins un peu d'honneur et le parti
socialiste se réunit aujourd'hui pour
vous
quand vous avez une histoire aussi
grande et puissante dans la vème
république et se retrouver aujourd'hui à
renier tout ce qui a fait ce qu'il
représente ce qu'ils sont c'est quand
même moi je fais la politique pour des
convictions le croit croire bien sûr mon
pays et dans ce que je propose dans ce
que je déforme et un grand nombre de
socialistes sont pareils et aujourd'hui
ils s'asseyent sur l'europe sur toutes
sortes de projets qui représentent
vraiment les fondamentaux du ps
d'ailleurs je pense que à l'intérieur du
ps les grandes figures du parti
socialiste nous n'adhérons pas à la
stratégie de désertion de monsieur faure
renaud muselier comment vous comptez
prendre votre part dans ce nouveau
quinquennat qui s'annonce comment vous
comptez pesée est ce que pour vous il
faut vous qu'est le président de région
évidemment est ce que notamment il faut
revoir totalement la méthode entre
emmanuel macron et les élus locaux
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que le
maquereau un maquereau ne doit pas
ressembler à maquereau et
on a pu voir que cet homme de 40 ans qui
a pris le pouvoir
avec une beaucoup de talent réussi à
être réélu avec encore plus de talent
c'est un homme qui ne connaît jamais
deux fois les mêmes erreurs que j'ai pu
approcher au fil du temps et qui est en
termes de méthodologie travail
d'intelligence et d'organisation tout à
fait exceptionnel il ne faut pas le
sous-estimer
donc pour ma part moi qui suit
présidents des régions de france le
président délégué je souhaite qu'ils
aient une vraie décentralisation et il
est absolument nécessaire pour apaiser
le pays de s'appuyer sur les corps
intermédiaires pour les régions on a la
capacité de cette forme de
décentralisation d'autonomisation avec
deux parlements régionaux de faire en
sorte que l'on puisse mieux travailler
sur la santé comme on le demande depuis
longtemps mieux travailler sur
l'environnement dans lequel nous sommes
très actifs il ya donc comme ça un
certain nombre de dossiers très
spécifique qui ne doivent pas être pas
être centralisés qui ne doivent pas être
était pas paris qui peuvent être traités
par les rayons par les départements ou
par les municipalités chacun dans son
domaine d'action nous avions fait
territoire unis avec le président
larcher avec le président de la mfr
des départements de france où nous
avions fait des propositions très
claires de décentralisation sauf que
vous n'avez
qu'à écouter vous n'avez pas été
entendus renommée des pourquoi vous le
serez selon vous dans ce second
quinquennat
et écouter une fois qu'on sera pas
entendu le et bien c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas été écouté une fois qu'on ne sera
pas entendue pour la suite vous savez la
vie politique c'est pas parce que nous
exprime une fois qu'on aimait une idée
qu'ont fait les propositions qui me that
man ils doivent être hyper être acceptée
s'achemine ça évolue ça avance bon pas
dans un nouveau quinquennat moi j'ai des
choses à proposer et je préfère le faire
en ayant l'oreille du premier ministre
ou du président de la république et
faire en sorte que je leur fais des
propositions concrètes comme j'ai pu le
faire en tant que président de région de
france où pour ma région où nous avons
débloqué la ligne nouvelle par exemple
provence côte d'azur qui était bloqué
depuis près de 15 ans voilà donc ce sont
des dossiers sur lesquels en place et
nous avons travaillé sur orbite et renée
ensemble sur cette politique
géopolitique locale sur le bassin
méditerranéen qui est absolument
indispensable on a pu le faire avec
monsieur le drian il ya plein dossier
sur lequel on peut avancer où nous avons
une capacité d'action comme nous n'avons
pu le faire la rapidité de l'action avec
nos adresses avec nos hôpitaux pendant
la crise sanitaire et ceci alors que le
gouvernement mais j'étais pas fait
parfaitement en phase avec monsieur
virant mais si la crise sanitaire n'a
pas été bien traitée pendant les 3
premières vagues ont pour reconnaître
qu'ils ont bien traités dans la
quatrième et la cinquième ouais c'est ça
la réalité et série monsieur le maire
que nous avons travaillé sur les
fonctions dit d'arrêter des pas des
nationaux monsieur l'aide à nos
entreprises sur l'aide et qui fait en
sorte qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
faillite en france c'est bien grâce à ce
travail qui a été fait par les régions
et pas avec le gouvernement donc tout
n'est pas tout blanc ou tout noir et
nous qu'elles ont été au pouvoir à
l'époque on se rend bien compte que on
réussit pas tout donc il faut revenir
réexpliqué amendé évolué et avancer un
mot sur une réforme qui divise c'est la
réforme des retraites renommée est ce
que pour vous il faut faire cette
réforme des retraites est ce que c'est
un une bonne réforme un bon signal pour
apaiser un pays qui était intime
alors il ya une double question c'est
est ce qu'il faut faire cette réforme
oui est ce que c'est un moyen pour
apaiser pour un pays rue petit ce nom
c'est la difficulté de la gestion de
notre pays est indispensable son sérieux
il faut la faire essayer une évolution
pour la pénibilité
il fallait il faut la faire en tout cas
donc il faut la faire mais il faut la
faire une façon à il faut la chasse
façon apaisée mais savez la vitesse va
aussi vitesse parfois la précipitation
vitesse précipitations lui dire éruption
donc oui il faut on l'a fait dans les
normes comment le polar incluse est là
pour calmer les choses donc il faut la
faire mes armes et on n'échappe au
gouverneur moi je vous posais une
question par rapport à la méthode est
donc par rapport à la méthode je dis oui
il faut le faire ça me paraît
indispensable il faut le faire de façon
apaisée ils ont de la vitesse et la
précipitation mais pas rappelle me
paraissent pas être la meilleure réponse
à cette question un dernier mot renaud
muselier puisque on commémore
aujourd'hui les 30 ans de la catastrophe
de defour yann un hommage sera rendu ce
soir au coup d'envoi de la demi-finale
de coupe d'europe entre l'om et faille
aux normes est ce que vous auriez
souhaité ce report du match
oui vous savez que ce médecin j'ai
soigné à l'époque les patientes qui nous
avaient été envoyés de corse sur
marseille puisque nous sommes la
destination directe dans nos hôpitaux
dans l'urgence dans nos centres de
rééducation j'ai soigné
personnellement mon ami monsieur jean
baptiste dumas qui était l'envoyé
spécial de rtl
rien que d'en parler j'en ai encore la
chair de poule c'est pour lui un grand
nombre d'années après j'ai participé
avec son fils et le comité de cheria ni
à la loi votée au parlement pour
interdire les matchs en france le 5 mais
bon là c'est une coupe d'europe donc bon
malheureusement que ça ne s'applique pas
mais bien sûr je suis très attentif à ça
et faire en sorte que ça ne se rendrait
jamais et je pense que tout le monde l'a
bien compris en france et dans toutes
les instances sportives et sur le plan
sportif on imagine que vous serez
vélodrome ce soir même d'aller en finale
écoutez puisque finalement cette date
commémorative n'est pas une bonne date
en sorte que l'om ça lui porte chance
ces cobayes après en albanie d'ailleurs
à tirana pour la finale
la coupe d'europe donc oui on va gagner
blessures merci merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin depuis
marseille président de la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur
[Musique]